being in a car accident that was very
scary to see your significant other just
being you know bloodied and
discombobulated it was hard to see that
was it one of those moments where
everything started slowing down for me
it wasn't slowed it was all very fast
for me personally when she kind of came
to after she hit her head really hard
she was already kind of like making
little jokes I blacked out about 15 to
20 minutes after the accident because I
don't remember any of it he says I was
still conscious but I don't remember any
of that surely when things happen like
that it really makes you realize how
special every moment really is
that devastating car accident happened
December 12th the very next day Derek
and Haley learned about their friend
twitch's heartbreaking suicide the two
attended his memorial last weekend took
me like I think like two days to like
cry you know it was my All-Star on so I
think you can dance so it was
it was tough that was a tough one too
and just recently being there at his
40th and talking with them I even had a
friend two weeks prior to that you know
unfortunately go the same way and
I had I felt this desire to say
something because I've worked in that in
that area with mental health and suicide
prevention
in the past I wanted to say something
and but I didn't and it for whatever
reason I just it just I just didn't you
start going through all sorts of
thoughts you know and things of like why
what if I would have and who knows and
but man he his legacy is forever intact
with especially the dance community
just a person who lives so beautifully
and impacted so many we just love him we
love Allison and their beautiful family
and uh
yeah we'll always be there for them
no wonder you want to be home right all
the time I met up with Derek and Haley
at the LA home they share it's where
they're planning their upcoming ideas
[Music]
so how are the plans going we finally
picked a date and a location we did we
found this
okay so give us a hint of what your
perfect wedding will look like
surrounded by Nature
and just magical I think that's exactly
what it's gonna be fireworks
explosions
pyrotechnics really he does he that was
his number one thing I actually do want
that
gotta do a first dance yeah it'll be
it'll be cool have you picked out a song
we have a song
right really I was like what is it right
we have a few actually but you're right
we have a few but the ones specifically
and that's the one where I hear and
here's here's the fireworks
that is the like the producer the
Visionary the creative in him so first
thing it's gonna have fireworks
we're in the car driving like all right
babes right here what gets quiet you're
gonna hear the
just
okay if you two had that conversation
about family oh kids yeah well I mean
well it wasn't really in like there
wasn't a rush on it until we just met
Val and Jenna schmerkovsky's baby and
that was when it was kind of like what
so should we get on this now let's do
this right let's go but it was pretty
special and actually it was cool because
Val
um he was like yo bro
he's like bro
um for somebody who was created to
create this will be your ultimate
creation so let's put that
yeah do it and then we'll do it
foreign